abone ol
bu hoşgeldiniz Ben Esma Alper henüz 15
yaşındayım üç yıldır halter sporunu
yapıyorum 2019 yılında katıldığım
İsrail'e Kargo Şampiyonası'nda Avrupa
şampiyonu Oldum tabii
da yaptıktan kenara yazıyorum ya
abone ol
Eğer bu iki video için yaklaşık üç yıl
çalıştım diyebilirim Çünkü halde dik
başladığımdan beri tek hayalim de
tekerleri değil alsın Türkiye şampiyonu
olmak değil hayalim Çünkü küçük hedefler
koyup daha çok daha çok büyütmek bana
daha çok güven kazandırıyor da Açıkçası
bu yeni insanlarla tanışmayı onlarla
kaliteli vakit geçirmeyi seviyorum Abant
ve bana ilk soruları halsteren neden
arter neden artere başladın oluyor Ben
harfleri 13 yaşında bir Okulumuzun alt
katında başladım açıkçası derslerden
sıkıldıkça ve sayısal sevmediğim için
olabilir Bir ve Hani ben harfleri bir
amacım olduğu için Gitmiyorum açıkçası
Çünkü tek amacım Hadi derslerden
sıkıldığım için daha sonra antrenörü ve
beraber hem dedi ki bunun hani ya
geleceksin gelmeyeceksin Hani bu şekilde
devam edeceğim ben seni sonra alamam
dedi ben son dedim
ben bunu yapmam gerekiyor çünkü Cartel
diğer sporlara göre çevreden daha çok
oynuyor bir gören bir spor ve ben bunu
açmak istiyorum çünkü ailem annem ve
babam İlk başlarda çok tepkilerdir bu
halter spor yapmama istemiyorlardı Hatta
bazen söylemeden bile gidebiliyorum
onlara Hani arkadaşlarımla gezdim
diyordum ama antrenman yapıyorum daha
sonra burası spor salonuna gitmeye
başladım Türkiye şampiyonalarına gittim
benim kazandım daha sonra iki yıl
geçtikten sonra bir Türkiye şampiyonası
hazırlanmaya başladım ve milli takım
seçmesi ydi Bu ve çok önemliydi çok
hazırlandım ve diğer maçlarda kendini
yetersiz ettim sabah 9'da girdim spor
salonundan gece 11'de çıktım oldu ve
Hani Dışarıdan bakıldığında çok anormal
gibi gözükebilir Ama sevdiğim işi
yaptığım için aslında kendinle gurur
duyuyordum daha
bu Türkiye Şampiyonasına gittik ben
antrenörü ve babamla birlikte hani babam
benden daha çok heyecanlı diyebilirim
tribünden Hani o kaldırdım yere kadar
sesi geliyordu Hani babama Şöyle Baktım
hadi babacığım sakin ol falan ama babam
hani sesi geliyordu Ve o zamanlar bir
Elektrikler gitmişti Babam da bana bir
şey oldu sandığını hani bir şey mi oldu
diye bağırıyor sonra ben son Kaldırımı
yaptım ve Türkiye'de koruyucu bu hani ve
Türkiye rekoru 80.dhy ben 90 kaldırdım
Hani bayağı bir çalışmanın emeğini
almıştım diyebilirim hocam Gökhan Göktaş
da beraber daha sonra ben arpa
Şampiyonası için milli takım seçmesine
girecektim Hani federasyonda
yayınlanıyor bu isimler Hani ben
yayınlandı herkesi yayınladı baktım
Benim ismim yok Hem de neden yok benim
ismimi ben hani rekor kırmak için diğer
bisiklet yarış Mıştım ve Beni almadı
almamışlar yani ya da yazmayı unutmuşum
bu daha sonra antrenörü mani konuştu
diğer isimler de eklendi ve o gün çok
ağladım diyebilirim Çünkü ben o kadar
çok çalışmıştım ki ve herkesin o kadar
isteği varken Hani girmemek beni mutlu
eder diyebilirim iki buçuk aylık bir
kamp sürecimiz oldu hani bu iki buçuk ay
boyunca o iki buçuk ay bana iki buçuk
yıl gibi geldi diyebilirim çünkü hani
Fix bir döneminiz oluyor sabah-akşam
antrenman yemek işte uyumanız uyumanız
her şeyi saat liydi daha sonra hani
kampı sonlarına doğru bir seçmeler
oluyor falan biz Hani hep beraber böyle
bir çileye girmiş durumdaydı Çünkü kimin
gidip şimdi kalacağı belli değil her an
her çıkışlı Biz çıkış yapıyoruz mesela
Her çıkışta bir şey olabilirdi her gün
biri gidebilirdi ve böyle gidiyorduk
antrenmana nasıl psikoloji bozuk ama
anlamışsınızdır sonra annemler gelmişti
ve babam gelmişti bugün antrenman ımıza
ankara'daydı bizim kampımızı o gün hani
iyi Anıtkabir'i ziyaret etti falan ama
benim gideceğim Hala verdi Ama onlar
hani Esma tamam İsa ile gidecek diye
bakıyorlar daha sonra gideceğim tamam
belli oldu işte maşa girdim Hani bu
İstiklal Marşı'nı okuduğunda kestiği
şifre değişemem diyebilirim Çünkü
düşünebiliyor musunuz o kadar kişi
ayakta İstiklal Marşı'nı okuyor ve Hani
o zaman İsrail derken hani çok normal
gibi geldi diyebilirim Çünkü ben dışında
daha çok sporcu vardı orada ve herkes
derece almıştı sona havalimanına
geldiğimde İşte herkes şey diyordum
pankart hazırlamışlardı ve Hani beni
karşılamışlardır il müdürümüz işte
Kulübü'nün ilk adım belediyenin çalış
şey müdürleri vesaire sonra Günler
geçtikçe ben ne kadar büyük bir şey
yaptım farkına vardım çünkü benim asıl
amacım hem arpa şampiyon olmak hem de
Türkiye Büyük başarı getirmekte
kapımızın ortalarına doğru Türkiye'de
Barış
bu hayatı vardı ve şehitlerimiz vardı
biliyorsunuz babam bana mesaj attı
antrenman Antremandan çıktım her gün
bana bunu hatırlatıyordu hani kendin
için olmasa bile Türkiye için ya da o
şehitlerin için yapmalısın bu dedi hani
beni en büyük mutlu eden şey diyebilirim
babam ve annem onlara çok teşekkür
ediyorum maça girmeden önce antrenörün
vesilesiyle bir video aldım Sevgili
Murat Turan spor ilçe müdürümüz işte
başarabileceğimi bana çok güvendiğine
belirtiyor Zaten sürekli antrenmanlarını
ziyaret ediyordu çok yakından
ilgileniyordu Ben de ve Hani o videoyu
almak annem babam zaten sürekli
antrenörü sürekli ben neler ama
başkasından bir video almak beni çok
mutlu etti açıkçası Çünkü Düşünsenize
Hani sen bir başarı elde ediyor Sana da
beni belli değil son o kadar destek
çıkan var arkamda bir sürü kişi var ve
Ya kusura bakmayın bizim jenerasyonu muz
için sorumluluk alamayan tembel çocuklar
gibi bakılsa da siz büyükler Bize biraz
destek olsanız hayal kurma ve dev hedef
vurma da biraz önümüze açsanız birçok
şeyi başarabiliriz bunu nereden
biliyorum Ben kendimden biliyorum Ben de
normal bir çocuktum Okulu'nda evinde
normal her şeyi düzgün çocuk ama ben bu
başarıyı elde etmem onların
yapabileceğini gösteriyor borç Çünkü biz
çocuklar şu an sosyal medya çok yakınız
Çünkü teknolojinin içine doğmuş
bilirsiniz bu bizim suçumuz olmadığına
göre herkesin Elinde telefon var
telefonlar tek bizim için değil bütün
herkes için altı diyarına gelmiş bir şey
be ve bu bizim bizi suçlamaları biraz
garip oluyor açıkçası ama hani bizim de
biraz
bu göstermemiz gerekiyor öğretmenlerimiz
tarafından bize hangi amaçla okul Hani
hangi amaçla üniversiteye girmemiz ya da
hayatımızı kurtarmamız gerektiği
anlatılması gerekiyor onların önünü
açılması gerekiyor çünkü farkında olmaya
biliyorlar kendilerine sosyal medya
katıla biliyorlar var sosyal medya
ilgisi varsa ve aileleri tarafından hani
çok belirginse bu özellik Demek ki
onunla ilgili bir iş yapacak ya da ona
ilgisi var Çünkü herkes Anadolu
Lisesi'nde okumak zorunda diğer ya da
herkes bir iş sahibi olmak ya da düzgün
mühendis Doktor avukat olmak zorunda
değil ve sosyal medyada bir iş yapmakta
ayıp değil yani ve Böyle kişiler
yadırgamam acısı Ben önceden çok
yazıyordum Çünkü biz Hani TikTok vardır
biliyorsunuz Biz hani TikTok çekmek çok
ayıp geliyor benim gözümde hala birazdan
öyle şey geliyor ama şaka maçlarını
kızlar başladı ne kadar kötüler Hani
böyle çok itici geliyordu açıkçası sonra
kampın Sonlara doğru onlar gitti işte
Oh oturdu çıktı Canım sıkıldı TikTok
çekelim mi dediler bir anda kendimizi
kaptırdık Hani düşünebiliyor musunuz
Hani ben buradan bu seviye gele
biliyorsan Herkes bu sosyal medyanın
içinde hangi duruma geleceği belli değil
Çünkü sosyal medya ve internet içine
çeken bir durum açıkçası ve şuan tüm
dünyada bir internet gitse herkes işsiz
yada Hiçbirşey olmuyor Olabilir çünkü
biz çocukların okuldan sonra vaktimiz
vaktimiz var dörtten sonra saat kaça
kadar Kim bilir ders çalışmak yerine
TikTok çekiyorlar ya da sosyal medyada
bir şeyler yapabilir Çünkü sokakta
yürüyorsunuz bakıyorsunuz hani biri var
ya böyle telefonu karşısında oynuyor onu
çeken bir sürü kişi işlemini böyle
yazıyorsunuz falan siz büyükler
tarafından biraz hani şöyle bakıyor
Çünkü sizden çocuklarınızın Tabi başka
yerlerde gözükmesini istemezsiniz daha
okul çapında işte okuyucusu olsun
fotoğrafları
Evet bu şekilde isterseniz ama onlar da
o şekilde Demek ki Yapmak istiyorlar
beni dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür
ederim uykular